talk I'm giving today is largely based
on this paper that four of my colleagues
wrote recently in which we
- at how causal bias and your data can
affect how that can affect the fairness
of the models that you make before I get
to the experiment though I'd like to
start with a question and I don't really
have an answer for all of you for all of
your models but I do have some questions
to ask so the first question even before
what is fair I suppose is why do we care
that our models are fair machine
learning models get used in a lot of
places nowadays and some of these places
are very consequential for example most
people don't have enough cash to buy a
house just straight up so they need to
borrow money and people that lend money
want to make sure that they're lending
money to people who can pay that money
back and so in order to make these
decisions at scale very quickly they
turn to machine learning models so those
models we want to make sure those models
are fair right there are people who want
to who have the hope of taking human
bias out of the criminal justice system
using models and so there's there's a
hope that maybe you can use models to
predict how likely somebody is to commit
future crimes and that you can be
simultaneously more fair and more
accurate and so these models are getting
used all across the country today to
make decisions about whether people go
to jail and whether people get parole so
those models we care about those models
being fair yeah sometimes models are
maybe a little more trivial sometimes
your machine learning models are
targeting advertisements of people I
would argue that even in cases of
targeting ads for for sandwiches or
movies or things like that that bias can
be important but sometimes ads are
sometimes advertisements are very
consequential - for example you might
have advertisements about jobs and there
have been studies about how a machine
learning targeting can can be biased and
showing people jobs that sometimes high
income jobs and low income jobs get
preferentially shown to different
subgroups of people and that
and have a big effect on people's lives
just knowing whether the opportunity is
available or not so maybe I've convinced
you that your models should be fair that
you should be thinking about this we
still need to know how do we measure
whether or not a model is fair and if
you can so yeah how do you measure
whether or not your model is fair and
this this may seem simple to you at
first maybe you already realize that
there's some subtleties but let me give
you one more concrete case study study
so this really came to prominence for me
with this ProPublica article a couple of
years ago there's a an algorithm called
compass compass is used to predict
recidivism whether or not a prisoner or
a somebody being charged with a crime
will commit future crimes so when a
person is arrested they'll enter their
demographics and information about
previous arrests where they live things
like that into this system the compass
algorithm will give them a risk score
rating how likely they are to commit a
future crime and the makers of compass
as I understand it intended this to be
used in distributing scarce resources
for rehabilitation but in practice a lot
of judges were using this for for more
than that they were using this to
determine for example whether people
would even get bail or whether they
would just be kept in jail and so that
we care about fairness they're
Republican pratense of examination
there's actually a notebook online with
the results of their analysis that you
can look up but they found that
analyzing the scores given by compass to
defendants and comparing that to whether
or not these people had committed crimes
after being released from jail
they found that compass was biased for
for white defendants the algorithm was
much more likely to incorrectly say that
they would not commit a future crime and
for african-american defendants the
algorithm was much more likely to say
that they would incorrectly say they
would commit a future crime so to many
more false negatives
white defendants more false positives
for black defendants and again false
positive here means that these people
might be denied bail something that I
found really interesting when I started
digging into this more is that North
Point the makers of the compass
algorithm in 2009 they published a paper
studying the the fairness of the compass
algorithm and they were actually more
concerned about gender bias here it
turns out that there's significant
differences in recidivism behavior
between men and women and it's difficult
for algorithms to get that right so they
were very interested in in showing that
their algorithm was correctly accounting
for gender differences and they they
argued that their algorithm was in fact
predicting well for both men and women
but they also looked at race and the
road that I've highlighted here is is
showing you the au C's of the models on
white and african-american defendants
and North Point says looked at their
algorithm algorithm and said it was
equally good for both races and so
everything's great
ProPublica article actually acknowledges
this as well they they check the
accuracy of the algorithm and they found
that overall accuracy was the same
between races no difference and and yet
ProPublica argues and i would tend to
agree with them that the false positive
and false negative rates are actually a
bit more consequential here so this is I
think an interesting case the the makers
of this algorithm cared about bias and
they checked for bias and they concluded
there wasn't any bias and yet someone
else coming by later did another check
looked at it a different way and said
this actually is very biased and this is
a problem so there are some subtleties
going on with determining whether or not
your algorithms are fair where does bias
come from so your training your models
on data where does the data come from
what makes up the data and you have to
look at whether the data are balanced or
imbalanced and potential sources of bias
in the data for example there's
different ways the data could be biased
or balanced or imbalanced and the first
thing to consider is that maybe reality
just
is not different between your protected
classes for example breast cancer the
rates of breast cancer are extremely
different between men and women go out
looking at it the other way the rates of
prostate cancer are extremely different
between men and women and if you're
making a classifier for this one metric
that people often use to measure
fairness of models is called disparate
impact as far as I know disparate impact
is the only metric that actually shows
up in United States case law it's been
used to argue on a legal framework that
that algorithms are illegally biased but
if you look at disparate impact it's
comparing the rates of positive
predictions for each of the protected
classes and it's asserting that these
rates should be the same if you're
making a classifier for something like
breast cancer or prostate cancer then if
your classifier actually passes this
test I would argue it's doing a very bad
job so even if your data are balanced so
reality is completely indifferent to
your protecting classes you you never
are privileged to train on all of the
data perfectly sampled you're always
taking sub-samples bias samples maybe
you look at at proxies for the thing you
actually care about one way that you can
get bias into your training data even if
the trip even if ground truth is
balanced is through what's called label
bias with label bias your your labels
for the classes have causal influence
from your protected classes as a
concrete example there's a study looking
at how teachers rated kindergartners
problem behavior and they showed that
the teachers actually actually had
different thresholds for suspending
children based on race the same problem
behavior was much more likely to get a
child suspended if that child were
african-american or Hispanic and and so
if you were making a classifier for
predicting whether or not kindergartners
were going to have problems and might
need extra help if you use whether or
not the child that had been suspended
previously as your label then you're
introducing bias into your training set
so even if the labels are good you might
get
you might get biased through what's
called sample bias with sample bias you
are preferentially including or not
including individuals in your sample at
all based on their protected class
concrete example would be stop-and-frisk
policies so stop-and-frisk
is a policy whereby police officers can
stop individuals on the street and check
them for illegal firearms drugs anything
there they're not supposed to be
carrying and there's been some evidence
that at least in some cases police
officers have different thresholds of
suspicion for stopping persons of
different races so even if the police
officers are equally good at checking
all of these individuals for contraband
equally likely to find contraband on
everyone just the fact that the process
of including them in the data set at all
is biased
can now introduce that bias into your
models training set another fairness
metric that you might look at is what's
called equal opportunity so an equal
opportunity you are looking at the rate
of true positives for each of your
protected classes and you're asserting
that the rate of true positives should
be the same so this sounds great but if
your dataset has this kind of causal
bias and a label bias or sample bias
then asserting that you should have the
same rate of true positives you might
actually be creating a biased model and
finally you want to think about what it
is that your model is doing if your
model is sending people to jail then
maybe it's worse to have false positives
than to have false negatives if your
model is handing out money for loans
then maybe it's worse to have false
negatives than to have false positives
there's not there's not a
one-size-fits-all solution for this
you've got to think about what it is
that you're building the model to do I
think when models first started being
used in that scale in the public people
had this idea that models are math and
math doesn't care who you are it doesn't
care about protected classes so as long
as we use models to make our predictions
then everything will be fair we're all
good we're taking bias out of the
process I think that now people have
come to the realization that this isn't
case and hopefully I've given you a
little bit of evidence how that might
not be the case but there's there's now
a push to try to fix this in in ways and
you can fix this by trying to look at
different metrics for predicting
fairness you can try to fix this by
modifying the training process of your
model and if you can encode your ethics
into your loss function which can be
possible in certain cases then you can
enforce fairness in your models but you
still have the same issues in in adding
constraints to your models so it's not
it's not the case that you can add it
pick one constraint off the shelf add
that in everything's automatically taken
care of all right so on to
experimentation so
we took a data set from some services
consulting work and we wanted to see how
easy it would be to predict bias in this
data set using some of the metrics from
the literature and the data set that we
used the features are demographics on
individuals and the outcome is the model
probability that an individual will sign
up or not sign up for a particular
service and in this data set the bias
that we're looking at is racial so some
of the individuals in the data set about
10,000 individuals are labeled as being
African American 120,000 individuals in
the status set were labeled as being
white and from the original data set we
will run two different experiments and
one experiment we artificially make we
artificially balanced the data set so
we'll select out only the 120,000
individuals who had been labeled as
white we'll remove the race label and
randomly race reassign either an African
American or white label for the second
one we'll keep the original data set
which contains imbalance different
numbers of individuals label as being
different races the individuals labeled
as African American had a with a point 5
threshold I think they had a 10% 10% of
them signed up for the service and 50%
of individuals labeled as white signed
up for the service so that there's
imbalance in that data set
now we take these two different
experiments and each experiment will
introduce known levels of bias to
introduce known label bias
we'll take those model probabilities
which we're now assuming to be ground
truth and we will threshold them
differently based on race so we'll make
it will will make it easier for the
label to be positive if the race is
white harder if the race is labeled as
african-american and for unbiased data
we'll just set that threshold of 0.5 for
everyone to introduce known sample bias
we will sample people differently based
on race so make it easier if your race
is labeled as white we'll make it easier
to include you in the data set if your
score is high harder if your score is
low so for the first case label bias
that's like the kindergartner problem so
your label is going to be you have
different thresholds for assigning
people to label for this case the sample
bias this is like a bias stop-and-frisk
policy where your your label could be
fair but your likelihood of being in the
data set it all depends on on your
likelihood it depends on the probability
of what your label is so now two
different experiments we have four data
sets for each one data set with no
causal bias at all one data set with
only causal label bias one data set with
only causal sample bias and one data set
with both causal label and causal sample
bias for each of these four data sets
well we train a logistic regression
classifier on the data and make
predictions and now we'll run each of
those we'll run all those predictions
through our fairness metrics in the
paper we consider six different fairness
metrics but for this for the purposes of
this talk I've selected out four of them
hard to fit more on the slides and it
gets pretty complicated in the plots but
for these four I mentioned already
disparate impact which compares overall
rates of positive predictions and
equal-opportunity
which compares probabilities of true
positives for each of the protected
classes
there's also equal miss opportunity
which looks at rates of false positives
so this is something that you might care
about if you're making a recidivism
algorithm for example and then there's
difference in average residuals where
you take the model prediction the
predicted probability and compare that
to the label and for disparate impact a
value of 1 is fair and for the other
three values of zero are fair there so
with the balance ground truth where
we've artificially made sure that
everything is is equal then all of these
metrics detect bias some of them detect
bias a little better than others in
different cases interestingly the
difference in residuals is doing better
on label biased and sample bias not
quite sure why that would be the
situation is a bit different for the
imbalance data set but the imbalance
data set the good news is that all of
these metrics are still detecting bias
the bad news is that they're still
detecting bias even in the be unbiased
ground truth which is imbalanced in fact
is particularly different difficult to
tell the difference between the case of
no bias and the case of sample bias
sorry label bias and remember when
you're looking at these looking at these
metrics in practice you don't actually
know what the number would be what what
these metrics be telling you if your
data set were unbiased so when you're
looking at this one thing to remember is
that it's not actually you don't know
for sure if the metric is telling you
that your model is biased you don't know
for sure where the problem is it could
be that that your reality the thing
you're trying to predict really is
imbalanced and that the predictions are
reflecting that it could be that your
training set had introduced bias into
the training process and that your model
is now being biased maybe this is
obvious for some of you that biased
imbalanced data will look like bias but
I think it's it's worth emphasizing that
so there's no no trivial answers to
these problems so what can you do about
this kind of thing I'm not saying don't
use fairness metrics there's a lot of
different metrics in the literature
lotta different things to think about I
didn't even touch on for example
calibration which is making sure that
your probabilities are good
probabilities well calibrated
probabilities regardless of the
protected class membership that might be
a thing you care about but that alone
certainly won't guarantee that your
models are fair you have to consider
what it is that your model is doing as I
said whether you're you're doing good
things or bad things to people if you do
know what you're doing if you do know
what your model doing is doing consider
the social context you can potentially
enforce fairness to your model
by using one of many different
techniques from the literature there's
actually so these papers that I've cited
here are good papers and worth reading I
showed them mostly to convince you that
there is a wide literature there's a lot
of work being done on this topic that
you should look at if your models if you
care about enforcing fairness in your
models importantly you should make sure
that people from different backgrounds
are involved in creating your models
people with different backgrounds will
be able to think of different potential
problems in your data in different ways
that your models could affect the world
could affect the people that you're
making predictions about and don't skip
your your exploratory data analysis and
remember to look at what the predictions
that your model is making and try to
think about it from as many different
angles as possible so this is this is a
place where you're diverse team is
really going to come in handy thinking
about different impacts that your model
might have so when you're when you're
writing programs your computer programs
are going to your computer is going to
do exactly what your program tells it to
do no more no less right
I think machine learning is similar in
that you're if you have a training data
set and you're doing a good job training
training your model on this data set
then the model is going to reproduce the
statistical distributions in your data
set when it's making predictions it's
going to learn the data that you give it
it's not going to learn the data that
you wish you had or the data that the
world should have and so you need to
think about what predictions you're
making is is is your data are your data
the truth and if your data are the truth
are your data the truth that you want to
have in the world your models are going
to affect the world if if people aren't
making decisions based on your models
then why are you bothering to make these
models in the first place so people are
going to make decisions and these
decisions are going to change the world
so you should think about how your how
these decisions are changing the world
and whether it's the kind of change that
you think is is worth making so thank
you questions
have people looked into whether
increasing the model complexity in terms
of bringing in data from further afield
that's not necessarily obviously
correlated to the specific outcome but
may be related to the demographics would
potentially increase that fairness or
maybe introduce an element of
information that will affect the outcome
yeah that's that's a good question I so
one way of trying to ensure fairness is
to try to make sure that there's no
information about the protected classes
in the data it sounds like that might be
a little bit of what you're touching on
so more MORE including more information
to maybe try to drown out the impact of
the protected class and yeah so that's I
think again it depends on what your
model is trying to do and what your you
want your model to do because there are
inequalities in the world and it can be
that making the best predictions
possible making the best predictions
possible often reinforced the status quo
and it can potentially perpetuate
inequalities that exist already like
maybe if you're looking at loan
predictions loan loan risks then certain
people are going to be going to have
defaulted on loans at higher rates in
the past but that might be because of
circumstances beyond their control and
if you don't give them those loans it'll
be harder for them to get out of poverty
and get themselves to a position where
they will be able to repay loans at
higher rates in the future just for
example so including more data and
making better models is definitely a
good thing to do but it's not
necessarily going to make your models
fare
any other questions
so in government in other secretaries
they have sunshine laws where you can
you know get into government records and
you can actually find out like what is
going on so do you see something like
that for these models that are having
these outside in these outsized impacts
on people's lives like some kind of
sunshine sunshine law where they can get
into these models and run other kind of
experiments like ProPublica do yeah I
think that's a great idea because like
the ProPublica example if they hadn't
been able to run that experiment if they
hadn't had the data on the predictions
that the compass algorithm had been
giving in the first place then we never
would have known that that algorithm was
making those those bias decisions so I
definitely think that we're algorithms
are making these important predictions
that it should be much easier for
outside organizations to check whether
those algorithms are biased or not
there's there's definitely resistance to
that because a lot of these algorithms
are regarded as proprietary and the
makers of these algorithms don't want to
give up their trade secrets
so there's resistance but certainly for
for things like like recidivism I think
it's important to be able to look at
that and you can go beyond that
potentially by by instead of looking at
these things in bulk
having trying to require that algorithms
are more interpretable that you get
information about why algorithms are
making certain predictions and that can
help give the humans looking at those
predictions some idea of what of whether
or not those predictions might be biased
or not so adding more interpretability
to models can can I think help improve
fairness as long as people are looking
at those and thinking about them
hello I just have a question so if
you're building a model that is
prioritizing or optimizing for precision
and you have a highly in thousands data
said what are some sampling techniques
that you recommend for that so how do
you train a model in a very imbalanced
data set there's yeah there that's kind
of a separate literature training models
on imbalance data one thing that you can
do is trying to to resample the data so
that you get more examples of the rare
class so the model better learns those
distributions that could potentially
also be something that you can do in a
fairness context trying to change the
distributions within different classes
to better balance your training data
again that depends on social contexts
and what your model is trying to do I
know there's various various tools that
are built especially for training on
imbalance data so I recommend looking at
some of those
thanks for the great talk just wondering
do your can your fair neck fairness
metrics be applied when protected class
isn't actually included in the models so
for example if you're building a credit
model and you don't want to include
gender as a as a feature and then also
second part and order Python
implementations for these fairness
metrics to that we can use yeah so for a
lot of these prettiest fairness metrics
you have to know the label of the
protected class otherwise you really
can't check but you can you can
certainly do that whether or not the
protected class is included in the
training data or not and often it's a
good idea to not include the protected
class and the training data although I
will say that in in some of these
techniques for enforcing fairness in
your data you have to do that by
including the protected class label if
you know that label and you want to
enforce certain distributions and the
outcome probabilities then you can do
that for for specific packages that do
these I don't have names off the top of
my head but a lot of these are really
easy to implement yourself if you look
up the the particular metric for
comparing true positive and false
positive rates for example a lot of
these you can just get out of
scikit-learn and evaluate the metrics on
different protected classes and compare
them just just regarding the first
question I guess it's um yeah if the
feature maybe is included but of water
features correlate and maybe signal
might get into the model directly so of
certain correlates which entered it's in
the model would with the with the
fairness metrics maybe pick up that yeah
the fairness metrics won't tell you
influence of particular features but
they're looking at the outcomes and
whether the outcomes are are balanced or
fair between protected classes thank you
yeah that's definitely the case that
often features that you might not even
think of as being correlated with
protected class are sometimes very
correlated with protected class so this
statement putting fairness ahead of
profit that may be tough pill to swallow
for some for many right do you think at
a certain point maybe policy may be a
way to move things forward things
similar to GDP are something like that
yeah I I think that there's there's so
many subtleties involved in this that
it's hard for me to see how you could
craft a good good regulation around
saying that models have to be one way or
another and the the thing that I
highlight with disparate impact is is an
example of that but there's examples in
American case law where a disparate
impact metric of less than 0.8
represents unfair bias in your model but
sometimes that's not necessarily a bad
thing like with the cancer classifier I
think that gdpr is maybe pointing at a
better way to take this which goes back
to the earlier question about
transparency and if the regulations are
not necessarily around enforcing a
particular outcome or a particular
metric on models but if the if there's
regulations around enforcing either
transparency and predictions
availability to public scrutiny or in
model interpretability that's probably a
better direction to take regulations
I'm just adding on to that last
statement is there any type of push to
combine for-profit data with nonprofit
data
I mean credit institutions may have
biased against blacks and Hispanics for
loans but you know giving micro loans to
other countries with the same you know
minorities has a different set of rules
is there any thoughts around combining
you know different data sets to to
create more fairness overall with mouths
that's that's interesting idea I don't
think I've come across that before and
I'd like to talk to you after this about
that in more detail
any further questions
okay okay thank you let's please give
you a round of applause
[Applause]